Miss USA qui a été élue Miss Univers le
15 janvier dernier la plus belle femme
voilà du monde lors des élections Miss
universel qui est Miss Univers et Miss
France
américain
on a trouvé encore aucune vie sur notre
aucune autre planète c'est quoi le
concept de Miss Univers
monde c'est quoi le concept de mission
il y a personne ici qui pourrait
qui est génial nous on va au deux alors
voilà donc je vais vous passer le match
justement parce qu'il y a un truc qui
est très très drôle et que je vais vous
montrer aussi leur pays non non alors
d'abord le match de d'abord la gagnante
regardez vous me direz ce que vous en
pensez
[Applaudissements]
Kosovo a été pour le bureau
alors
[Rires]
[Musique]
France elle l'a foiré j'adore alors nous
notre mise à nous elle fait de la radio
avec Guillaume Genton que j'embrasse
donc elle s'est pas présenter c'est une
autre qui a rien gagné donc on s'en fout
ce qui m'amuse plus c'est que je vais
vous demander d'annoncer votre ville de
vous ah de naissance comme si vous étiez
amis univers alors on y va ça va donner
hein bon j'ai le François
attention
du Sud même si
[Applaudissements]
vas-y lion ah ouais ouais
tu veux la parler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regarde ce que tu vas avoir à côté
chez la foldingue je suis né à la mairie
de Paris moi c'était bien c'était bien
Paris avant quand
elle est bonne que la côte je dis ça
avec l'accent parce que là on a la ville
qui est géniale avec le mec
il n'en sais rien
[Applaudissements]
bourdi Mouchon
à côté du Casto pro du Brico pro
régional voilà
[Applaudissements]
tu vois tu la foireux
le meilleur pour la fin bizarre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'imagine 3 20 ans les soirées à fait
Miami
mais il a rien de bizarre maintenant
mais c'est vrai en général
[Applaudissements]